storefront signs in Arabic script are a
common sight in Dearborn a Detroit
suburb about half of this city's
population of 100,000 have Arabic roots
40 year old tiger eat ala watch arrived
with her family from Syria two months
ago called from many interviews and each
time they took all our information we
were hopeless we didn't think it would
work two of her children have
disabilities that may be one reason they
were given permission to enter the
United States this year the US will be
accepting about 10,000 Syrian refugees
that number may increase next year
nada Cordy who's lived in Dearborn for
years works as an interpreter she
volunteers to help Syrian refugees get
their bearings in a new country I'm
doing this first of all because I'm
Syrian and those are my people and I
need to be there next to them side by
side to make sure that nobody will use
them most Dearborn residents work in the
auto industry which hasn't fully
recovered from the 2008 economic crisis
but business is taking a turn for the
better
Ford has its headquarters here locals
are divided about whether Syrian
refugees should settle here too I
welcome everybody I have no problem with
the more diverse we get to learn more
about each other the economy is already
bad last thing we need is more people
trying to get more jobs it's not that
I'm happy I just don't think that we can
take all of those those refugees and
we're having a problem with finding out
ourselves you know for our young people
and our social services are you know
pretty good but it's draining the rest
of us access is the name of one social
service helping refugees settle in
Dearborn the staff sets up newcomers
with language courses health care and
jobs
those folks have a really high job
retention rate that means that when they
get that chance to be employed they work
very hard tag reads husband Hussein
found work in a slaughterhouse near a
mosque where many refugees go to pray
the state of Michigan is home to about
400,000 citizens of Arabic descent many
of them came to the US as refugees and
never left
but toggery the AL watch isn't thinking
that far ahead I miss my father I miss
my mother I miss my country there's no
country in the world like Syria it's the
most beautiful country in the whole
world no it's like no other country
would welcome you the way your own
country would sue do not iftar greed
I'll watch had her way she'd returned to
Syria immediately but that's unthinkable
until the war there is over